you
[Music]
so thanks for coming out I'm super
excited to host today as Smita and David
who are visiting from Columbia yeah
Yale sorry I'm gonna I was jumping ahead
did her postdoc at Columbia with Donna
yeah so she's been at Yale for last
three years now it was like mommy before
that so I'm off to guess or maybe I
shoulda stopped now but no I'm so they
don't talk a lot about high dimensional
learning for single cell in particular
and as I seen it came from Donna's group
at at Yale before that Michigan or maybe
it was again or something I don't know
they were was a University of Amsterdam
for his ph.d but he actually had spent
most of his time at Weitzman which is
you know right next door in Israel
working with Iran Segal and as now I
post talk with Smita at either Columbia
or one of those I will get on if you
want to ask a question type it in and oh
I'm gonna go get started if you have any
questions if you want to know more about
something I guess I hear you can ask me
right away or you can ask me at the end
and then David has extra slides on it
everything if you want to go into more
detail about anything specific now I'm
just going to talk about basically what
our group does
we're jointly located in computer
science and the medical school at Yale
and we're basically a machine learning
or applied math type group and we
developed techniques that are meant to
analyze complex biomedical data and can
usually or often be applied to other
types of types of data because we
believe that's a bar for analyzing
biomedical data is a little bit higher
because there's can be all kinds of
sparsity
missing information very very noisy a
lot of nonlinear effects and things like
that so we believe that if I may
basically we do unsupervised machine
learning technique so if we're able to
detect those sorts of patterns and
hopefully we can detect other other
sorts of patterns as well so as I was
mentioning our group develops techniques
that deal with data that can be very
high dimensional so you're measuring a
lot of different features often we apply
our techniques to single RNA sequencing
data where the features are transcript
counts mRNA transcript counts but we've
applied it on a variety of other data
sets also high throughput so there's a
lot of different units so we've tended
to work with single cell data where the
units are cells or data where the units
are patients but there's a lot of them
and there's a lot of heterogeneity
within the data set which means that we
want to learn what the different you
know ways that the data itself is
stratified what the different patterns
are how much information and redundancy
there isn't in the futures the
challenges this kind of data can pose is
as I mentioned there could be sparse it
even though there's many many features a
lot of them could be missing for a lot
of the data points there's a lot of
noise so there could be no very
extrinsic noise background ambient noise
or there could be specific types of
noise
there's non-linearity in sort of the
shape of the data and how the features
relate to each other and just a scale of
it can pose computational problems so
the algorithms need to be scalable so
with this kind of data one question that
we often ask is how do we look at this
data so how you might have a lot of data
and often you might not even have any
ideas what your data can tell you or
what can you even predict so in this
circumstance we have unsurprised
techniques that will help you just sort
of look at and explore the data to even
generate hypotheses from it
so some of the technologies in biology
that are generating this this scale of
data is math cytometry or sight off as
you mentioned which generates a lot of
protein channels RNA sequencing hi-c et
CR sequencing which I know a lot of lot
of you work with and and sort of the
list goes on this is and we think this
kind of thing just keeps exploding and
there's more and more technologies that
are capable of generating this so how do
we sort of deal with these challenges
and one of the themes that we've sort of
seized upon in our lab is the fact that
even even though the data is measured in
a high dimensional space it has
intrinsically low dimensional structure
so for example in the gene single RNA
sequencing world there are a lot of
genes that you measure but these genes
have a high degree of informational
redundancy between them and as a result
the cell types and states are
constrained so there's an intrinsically
Laura dimensional shape here so the
ambient space was a lot bigger than the
intrinsic shape and so that's one of the
principles we use in our lab how do we
learn this lower dimensional intrinsic
shape as you can see the shape can be
nonlinear how do we understand the shape
and ed1 of the fields and math that we
use a lot is grass signal processing
where there's a nice theory of manifolds
and we show that we can also implement
the same concept with deep learning
where not only does the data have have
shape but there is some smoothness in it
so the smoothness or the locality and
the data can really help you learn and
understand this shape they'll give you
sort of an example here smoothness
meaning your data points are occupying
the state space in some semi-regular
fashion even if they're not uniformly
sampled across it you have samples and
different parts of it so that you can
learn learn something about it it
doesn't have to be one
smooth shape it can be a collection of
them so basically if you have this kind
of highly nonlinear Laura dimensional
structure how do you learn it the very
basic way you learn it is you look for
very similar data points to every data
point and to some level of granularity
even if you have high dimensions and
noise you should be able to tell data
points that are very similar to your
point in a very local way so if you're
trying to look for points that are very
far away you can get lost because unless
you know this is structured like a Swiss
roll you might not understand the points
and the different arms are actually far
away but you can understand which points
are very close to each other so once you
would have points that are very close to
each other you can basically take a walk
by taking small steps to local neighbors
and this walk will somehow help you
clarify the shape of the data and find
this highly nonlinear intrinsic
dimension that the data follows so when
you walk in small steps you can define
Markov matrix that says starting from
any point you're gonna transition to
other points based on your measure of
similarity that measure of similarity
doesn't nearly it doesn't have to be
necessarily very perfect it can be
pretty rough but as you walk longer
distances the probabilities add up so
that you hone the longer you walk the
more you Honan and the main dimensions
of the shape so this is this concept is
called data diffusion or a random walk
and this data diffusion type concept
where you find these main nonlinear
eigen dimensions turns out to be the
sort of basis of graph signal processing
so we used this concept for the first
project that David and I did together
that was just published and so and it's
an algorithm called magic and what magic
shows is that by learning this manifold
of the data you can restore values to
cells that were missing or you can
denoise cells such that you can further
process them so restoring data basically
to the main manifold dimensions
the motivating problem was in single saw
RNA sequencing which came out about
three years ago you have a sell-by gene
count matrix but most of its missing
just by the way RNA capture works it's
like reaching into your cell and
grabbing five to ten percent of the
transcripts and the rest of them you
leave in the cell so given this a lot of
what I done with Saito for example in my
postdoc which is try to learn
relationships and signaling the
relationships between proteins could no
longer be done so if you're looking per
gene now and you're trying to get
information from your 20,000 genes as
far as which gene has a relationship or
correlation with another gene it becomes
very hard to discern this because you're
not seeing both the genes in the same
cell at all so if you only see one gene
and 10 percent of the cells and another
gene and another 10 razón themselves the
likelihood you're saying but genes in
the same cell is 1 in 100 and so a lot
of this data is dropped out and you
can't do the type of gene regulatory
analysis that seems to be promised by
the technology so the steps of magic
basically are that you start with a cell
by gene matrix you calculate distances
but again you don't trust far away
distances so you localize the distances
by passing it through a gaussian
infinity so that gives you very local
neighbors and then you Markov normalize
it to create a random walk matrix and
then you exponentiate this matrix to
compute the probabilities of longer
random walks and then this has honed in
on the main dimensions of the data so if
you eye can be composed it you'd get
what's called a diffusion map but we
don't actually I can decompose it you
basically project this operator onto
their data to learn a weighted average
of manifold intrinsic neighbors to get
the imputed data so you basically have
data before magic and after several
steps of imputation when you project you
get your restored data after magic you
can see some of the other types of noise
and the data besides missing values are
also restored and what the subsequent
steps of diffusion do are it connects
the manifold more and more
globally so you get more global
directions and as you do this you take
off the low noise dimensions and you
hone in on the main manifold dimensions
and you see restored relationships
purging and it can restore it to
nonlinear values because you're not
imposing any sort of global constraint
on the shape of the relationship or what
you impede yeah it's a single cell
they're two genes
two random genes you can think of it as
so this is a single sartet sequencing so
becomes molecules four genes assume so
these are molecule comes I tried to
understand what on the x-axis like how
do you determine their quality well each
expression level it's just two features
so you can think of it we had a matrix
with a bunch of missing data and I'm
trying to learn the relationship between
two columns of the matrix just to see if
the two columns have correlation so if
you had people I'm trying to figure out
if there's correlation between there I
don't know right and salary or something
like that but I just couldn't do it cuz
most of it was missing and when I
restored it I can restore the
relationship between these two features
so so I understand I have a I always
they say that you have a sparse matrix
matrix that's right but actually it's
not major to complete its itself harder
I'll talk about like yeah that mean that
this name is matrix completion so matrix
completion assumes that the values you
have in your matrix are okay and you
just have to compute missing values but
it's not this situation this situation
you see you under sampled everything so
you you have a small set of samples from
yourself and everything is under counted
what's a missing value exactly yeah
there's no exactly you know distinction
and algorithm doesn't distinguish like
that either
Oh something's highly expressed the the
chance
would be zero whispers pretty low right
you ain't got something that's got
thousands of trial well usually if we
see a transcript weeks it's pretty
trustworthy unless you have a mapping
what I'm saying is that it's not even
random in the sense that if something's
got lots and lots of transcripts and you
have a 10% chance of taking each one if
you have 10% chance of taking a thousand
things dogs are in zero or very there
yes yeah I can't beat transcript that
dominates all right cancers also
preserve yeah you might see a bit of
social psychology answer or exactly
something like them so then you
accentuated interesting sorry
interesting genes their little
experience like transcription factors
interesting stuff that is highly
expressed yeah unfortunately actin so
yeah exactly our soft surface markers
because then you can use them to sort
and study cells those are exactly
missing you mean before your imputation
so does that help answer your question
yeah and I'm not assuming you know what
these relationships look like although
if you know about epithelial to
mesenchymal transition in breast cancer
you know that this is a correct
direction of these relationships because
snail is a transcription factor and
momenta and is a mizenko marker so when
snail goes on momentum goes up and then
eco Darren and I meant and our markers
of epithelial versus mesenchymal state
so they're not on at the same time we
didn't try so Peter I have you made
recently so we did try matrix completion
techniques so we always try to find ways
to validate it computationally and
otherwise so here we had a gene of worms
that were developing for the first I
think it's 48 hours and they had both
sequencing but there was a natural sort
of manifold structure that we knew about
and we artificially dropped this data
out and weari imputed it with magic and
denoise did as you can see and the
original relationships got totally
messed up they most of it sunk down to
zero and then
Yury impute it with magic and you see
that the original relationship is
restored or even further clarified so
why is this interesting to us because it
sort of you can learn a lot about
individual genes now you can look at
their pairwise relationships their
individual probability distributions are
represented in and you can distinguish
between different populations and how
much of a particular gene is represented
you and in addition to looking at
individual genes the overall data is is
restored so this is before magic and
afterwards you see a very clear
structure of this data this is again
data that's mimicking the epithelial
mesenchymal transition on breast cancer
cells so we see different structures
corresponding to the yellow is missing
Komal cells that successfully
transitioned for example so one thing we
can do after magic that we completely
couldn't is do something called
archetypal analysis so there's data
before magic and after and the main idea
is to fit a polytope to the extreme ends
of the data to figure out what's
creating the overall shape and when we
did that we were able to identify sort
of extreme end points of this shape that
correspond to chromatin modification so
for example now biologists could look at
these intermediate states that people
hadn't really considered that much and
see that there is a sort of long program
of chromatin modifications that's going
on so a lot of times people hone in on
the first part of this which are
epithelial cells or the last part which
removes animal cells they're not really
sure how these cells transition through
the intermediate populations and that's
something that you can start to get a
picture of after you've restored
restored all your gene values this is
comparing magic against sort of matrix
completion in low-rank approximation
methods so you can see that NMC is
nuclear norm base matrix completion
the Candace based method and it doesn't
perform super well here Laura
approximation actually does somewhat
better but it's a linear method so it's
not completely denoising and then on
linear directions and then you see magic
restores sort of the data shape to
something that's identifiable to us we
measured it against a lot of other ways
so people often ask us you need this
sort of complicated random walk
technique and can't you just do this by
imputing with Kannon and you see it's
not nearly as good if you impute with
just your K nearest neighbors the global
manifold connections actually do make a
difference when you're when you're
learning the shapes and you can't use
individual diffusion components or
anything like that to get the same so it
can't be sort of just simple smoothing
on your graph so the manifold learning
actually makes a difference so after we
did this project so basically what we
did was we restored the gene values we
thought we could do similar inference
because we've learned the gene cell
graph on external variables and we
thought we'd this could really help us
because single-cell RNA sequencing data
now is not only in a single condition
but it can be generated in multiple
conditions and now people want you to
compare conditions so I have this single
cell data and I have it with
perturbation so what's the real
difference and you know measuring the
difference actually you know pretty hard
because for safa there's all this noise
that sort of occludes the difference but
also the measurement effect itself could
be weak or could be measured weakly and
so we thought we'd actually treat this
experimental variable itself as a
similar signal as we treated a gene and
use the same sort of graph manifold de
noising technique on an external
variable but you know it's configured a
little bit differently because we don't
know some things about the experimental
variable so this is a technique that's
in preparation so David is sort of
supervising this project and Jayne and
Dan are working on it
the idea is to smooth an external
perhaps experimental label on the data
graph to putative con
and infer associations so the idea here
is you have cells from condition1 and
condition2 but you've learned your graph
from single-cell RNA sequencing data
after from the whole data that you on
the genes and now you can sort of
interpolate the labels to get a
continuous variable that can now give
you some enhanced abilities to tell the
difference between the two conditions so
one thing it can do is it can improve
your ability to correlate variables with
the experimental condition so before you
had these discrete labels and between
condition and want and condition two
there really a significant difference
can you tell me often you can only tell
us it's a monotonic relationship like an
a but you can't tell a non monotonic
relationship like you have in B and so
after you we call these melding we've
turned it into a verb so we're melding
variables after we meld the variable I
mean for this latent dimension that
seems much easier to track to see if it
correlates with it with the experimental
condition so you can think of the MELD
dimension as a continuous experimental
variable the other thing you can do is
help us identify subtypes so if you have
condition a and condition B and you mix
samples from it you can see which cell
types are enriched in condition a versus
condition B so some of sort of the math
behind it there they're also using graph
signal processing so they D and graph
signal processing is you have a graph
and you're treating this variable as a
signal on that graph and what you're
actually doing is you're low-pass
filtering filtering this graph so like
before when you power the matrix what
you're actually doing is you're keeping
the high eigenvectors of this markov
matrix which arranged from 1 to 0 by the
properties of Markov matrices so
something is 1 to 0 and you raise it to
a power it goes down unless it's close
to 1 and that's the property that you're
using that's sort of smoothing on this
graph or smoothing on the laplacian so
you see that before the smoothing the
signal is kind of noisy it has all these
high frequency components and as you
smooth more and more you hone in on the
low frequency component so you're
smoothing the external variable along
the main directions of the graph
assuming that the mean
directions of the graph sort of
represent the difference what T would be
how much you power the matrix even
though in this set up we actually don't
power it we have it as a convex
optimization that trades smoothing with
reconstruction but in magic we had a TA
where you powered it how strong you
power how much you power or how much you
smooth so for example if you have time
series data and you're looking at the
expression of sox10 this is some
embryonic stem cell data you impute
continuity to this and then you can tell
there's two cell populations and one sub
population rapidly increases the
expression of sox10 which is a marker
for some lineage do you remember which
one right now and so in these kind of
inferences that you can make maybe even
more useful kind of inference we can
make we're testing it on this hip C data
so yells for the human you know
profiling project consortium so we get
basically signed off for C this is
single cell or any sequencing data from
these different infectious diseases so
this is Lyme disease analysis this is
the difference between a pivot a
patient's first visit and a patient's
second visit so we meld the visit label
and what we're starting this T is the
right side is colored by the melded time
so populations that are enriched at the
second visit are in the lighter colors
populations that are more common and
their first visit are in the purple
colors so you see the T cells there's
certain kinds of T cells that are
showing up in yellow and if you sort of
zoom in on them you seen that the second
visit there's certain regulatory to salt
populations that are appearing and
regulatory t-cells are actually quite
rare and it would be hard to pick this
out without meld smoothing the coloring
on the label and their memory T cells
that are upregulated and visit to and we
can generally see how these populations
you know arise and then maybe go away
with the different as the patients come
back and they're expected to come back
more and more time so we're excited
about using meld for this mm-hmm
you have a liar to labels and so I if I
understand correctly so I do it as you
can have more than two if you have time
steps like could have four or five but
in this particular case is how are you
have you will is like zero on one origin
story two on one
now you do the matrix pairings
eventually you'll guess a little bit
it's kind of a little bit like diffusion
there's some extent that's exactly it
okay so you have a soft probability yeah
yeah you have a soft probability that in
some respect you could interpret as sort
of a likelihood that it was generated by
condition two versus so so the minute
specific sentence setting the score can
be interpreted as something for example
these are two visits in time so now you
can say that we appeared at the time
right you know you measure two time
points we effectively at many time
points but it still a score how likely
that self you know came from come from
one sample one or simple to nesting so
when you generalize to a model and this
one Danny will become another Nami yeah
it would be a multi-dimensional and you
can do the same thing right
if you encode your condition with ten
bits you can meld all the ten bits
answer what do you think he's
hallucinating what happens in your
imputing physical analysis you haven't
done really you haven't changed the
situation at all if the doctor wants to
see whether there is a taking regulated
regulatory cells they would still do the
same for you darling so basically it's
not exactly correct so even if you have
to you can see if there's a strong
regression with the condition after Mel
that you couldn't move water and there's
you so imagine computing p-value to see
if the distribution is in
different like in this condition a
versus condition B you'll do some sort
of statistical test but I'm saying you
can do some kind of stronger inference
on the MELD dimension you can compute
the correlation with moreover a and C
you clues here you get the original data
right as you can see but B and you would
not yes can we zoom in on that was again
so what what about the data that you see
in panel would lead you to conclude that
so so to imagine so you have to
understand that each sample is very
heterogeneous right so there are some so
let's let's let's maybe go in reverse
let's assume that this is the original
is the ground truth okay this is the
original system but now you measure that
in two samples right so you've cut it
into one sampling and one sample here
the result will be this movement right
but there will be some cells here and
some cells here that were actually here
at the peak but you're missing that
information now but with milk you can
recover that yeah which ones are which
ones are closer to 1 and 2 versus part
of the way exactly their genes are
changing also yes you you learn the
manifold of the gene expression and now
you use that manifold to impute to
interpolate this external data it's
actually been shown you can have any
p-value show anything because everything
is rare 20,000 genes anything where they
look at this and say well maybe this is
happenings which have more samples in
between convinced that this is what's
going on rather than pretty
have you tried helping didn't know well
so one thing you could do is so you
originally measured two conditions
you don't melt and how you gain is into
three bins
and now you have three conditions and
now you can do the same things that
we've done we've validated it by doing
that we've left out a time point that
was actually measured and we've melted
on the two time points that are flanking
it and we can impute back the middle so
we've done validation right but we're
not super big on statistics because we
were like you know maybe they shouldn't
be generate some kind of null
distribution where you randomize things
and you could get a peanut but it's very
easy over easy to get good p-values that
way so highly note elimination yeah so
if you if you will do a random so then
another project that we did that sort of
uses these same ideas is we realize that
we have all this high dimensional
structure but we don't have a very good
way of visualizing this structure for
exploratory purposes so if we in in some
cases we knew genes we were interested
in so we're visualizing biaxial plots
another case we visualized PCA but it
came to our attention that all of these
methods sort of leave out a lot from the
data so because we learned the whole
manifold of the data there's should be
some way of visualizing it that
preserves structure a bit more and this
led to a project called fate that's
under revision now so the idea of fate
is that because we have a natural
understanding of the shape of the data
we can squeeze it into lower dimensions
in such a way that captures both local
and global structure and therefore sort
of trajectory structures in biology but
also the sperits cluster structures and
we realized that not a lot of other
visualization methods really preserve
structure structure in this way so I'm
gonna show this both on artificial data
and data
from an embryo a body differentiation
system when you start out with human
embryonic stem cells then you
differentiate them into a variety of
different lineages over a 30-day time
course so this artificial tree data
which might lab sometimes calls the dumb
tree but you'll find out that the dumb
tree is harder than it looks as you see
here so if you take this dumb tree and
you add noise to it and you rotate it in
high dimensions and you look to see if
you can visualize it if you try to
visualize it with PCA you're missing a
lot of the structure in the dumb tree
even though it picked up sort of the
global directionality in some way it is
going from blue to green but it's losing
a lot of the branching structure tease
me seems to be all the rage in this
field I'm not sure maybe in other fields
too but tease me actually sort of
shatters shatters the data in a bad way
because it only cares about keeping
stochastic neighbors together and we
believe that if you don't keep just
neighbors but keep manifold intrinsic
relationships altogether it's a better
way of preserving the structure in the
data and you see fate can preserve the
data but it can also denoise it which is
important in so you see the lines that
fate gives are thinner and also denoise
it in the manifold intrinsic dimensions
so here's fate shown on and we
especially hope that a lot of people
start using this because this basically
can work on any any type of data here
you see the embryonic stem cell
differentiation system the red to the
left is all embryonic stem cells because
that's from day 0 to 3 and we started
with 3 onyx M cells and as the days go
on you create the lineages that are
colored or colored in orange that we
picked up on days 6 or 9 and then
finally the blue where the latest did we
generated 24 through 2007 and again you
see PCA kind of picks up the alesis time
label and the fact that there's fewer
cells so there's less space occupied by
the red than the green and blue because
it's they're branching out as lineage
but the internal structure is not
clarified but teach me doesn't even do
that so this is very bad for preserving
continuum structures so you see the red
is shattered out to on either sides of
the green and the global relationships
are all completely messed up so can I
trust this for understanding really the
overall global structure of your data
diffusion maps which is somewhat based
on this it's based on this concept but
it's an older method it doesn't preserve
in a way that you can visualize
basically what it's doing is it's taking
each branch each trajectory to cluster
and putting it out to a different
dimension so you need to visual you need
to look at many many many diffusion
dimensions to get at this even though it
has some of this information and this is
how the fête algorithm works so the
first three steps are similar to the
steps that you saw before which is you
have the data you learn distances and
affinities and you power the matrix
although usually to a higher power
because you're visualizing in two or
three dimensions but then we use some
information theoretic techniques after
that so after that we realize that we
want to really preserve the information
in this matrix sort of information
theoretically as much as possible in low
dimensions so we come up with an
information theoretic distance between
these diffusion probabilities and then
again we don't want to lose any
information so instead of just
visualizing eigenvector 1 versus
eigenvector 2 which is what people do in
pca we squeeze all the variability in in
two dimensions by running metric MVS on
these informational distances that we
came up with so we're making sure that
we don't leave any information out there
that we haven't captured and that we're
capturing as much as possible in our
distances and the idea of using an
information theoretic distance is that
each point is a probability distribution
each point is a distribution between
affinities named probabilities of
walking and if you just took a straight
point wise distance it would be
dominated by what's happening with the
nearest neighbors and it would look a
lot more like tease me but if you use an
information theoretic distance usually
information theoretic distance
have a damping factor so you have a log
as you doing Shannon entropy so this
damping factor makes the low probability
differences full changes also picked up
by the distance and the idea again of
using metric MDS instead of eigen
decomposition is so that we only get two
or three or however many dimensions you
want and it's doing the best job it can
to preserve all this information and low
dimensions so that gives you fate and
here again we've these are ground truth
examples where we generated the stuff
that's on the first column so we
generated this and we see you know what
fate is giving us versus what other
other things are giving us sometimes the
other methods do do pretty well on sort
of like the Gaussian mixture model
sometimes they again do weirdly like tea
sneeze putting the green and red in
between the blue and orangish color
sometimes they're very noisy like I so
map can be very noisy because it's is
doing geodesic distances shortest path
distances their hardest path distance
and will take every shortcut they can
through every outlier they can there's
now you can see things like
force-directed layout that are just
trying to like splay things out and you
get what one of my students called
sneeze spots from it or it looks like
pointers sneeze out there's other
methods called monocle that fit trees to
data and it's not quite appropriate but
some reviewers asked us to compare
against against that and and then you
can imagine that it does the same thing
to biological data so there's different
types of data we visualize here the
first is our embryonic stem cell
differentiation data the second is
retinol bipolar data which they mainly
thought had a lot of clusters but we can
see that the clusters have some
progression within them and then there's
hematopoietic stem cell differentiation
data and a there's IPSC reprogramming
and E and when they're grayed out it
means those methods don't scale so we
had to so sample them to begin with
which turns out to be a huge problem for
most of these where's this kind of
diffusion process can be made made
really fast
using some tricks
[Music]
so this is a visualization of what fate
was trying to do it's trying to keep
global structure like like PCA but it's
also clarifying local structure because
they can denoise in nonlinear directions
and find nonlinear directions of
dimensionality so you get more
fine-grained detail than you would and
you can sort of zoom in on those fine
details and I have a Suman slide but we
can show for example that this orange
branch that the way it's splitting is
actually real and there's some
biological conclusions about what the
differences between those two retinal
cell types are so what can we do after
we run fake you can do a lot of
different things you can cluster around
the fake dimensions we compute intrinsic
dimensionality to find sort of branching
points if you have a lot of 1d
trajectories in your data branching
points have higher dimension locally we
can use these branching points in
conjunction with the clusters to come up
with sort of lineages or regions of
analysis and so we gave this kind of
analysis to our collaborator at the Yale
stem-cell Center and she was able to
play with this tool and identify a lot
of different lineages so she came up
with this tree of lineages and there are
several intermediates here that she did
not know so this is truly a troll toll
for people to visualize data their own
data from their own domain and figure
out what's in in the data and use it for
further analysis so we were able to sort
out some of the populations that she was
interested in and then she can fact sort
them and figure out what to do with it
next so the final project that I'll talk
about it kind of ties all of these
things together yes it seems like there
are two big thing ones when we saw by
using the division
whatever to do a small thing the other
one is you replace to do and then the
other one is you uses the information of
divergence well yeah so I'm wondering
whether you have you guys tried to
ablate the two aspect and see which one
yeah so actually all these steps are
essential there is it's a random
collection each of these steps is
essential for getting the end result so
if you remove the fusion doesn't work if
you're removing informational this and
doesn't work so all these are essential
steps and if you don't go from yeah
we've validated that every step is it's
basically necessary I would do we still
have that figure in the Varekai paper
no there's always constraints when you
submit was wondering because people use
this need for like gene expression
clustering and there I consider one big
difference is that the the cell count
that the transcript town is not noise
no it's the noise is this thing right no
it is it can be so I think that I think
these knees may be okay for some kind of
clustering because it kind of keeps
local neighbors together but if your
data doesn't have that kind of cluster
structure and it's it keeps them
together at a very particular
granularity that when you're ready Larry
is determined by the perplexity you set
in tase me so basically at that level of
granularity it's kind of splitting your
data out into clusters and I think
that's an okay use case for tasting but
this is not an okay use case if you're
trying to find the relationships between
your populations which clusters are
actually close to each other because
also the KL divergence penalty is very
lopsided it cares if you put close
neighbors far but there's no effective
penalty for putting far things close or
in any configuration but what tease me
does that PCA doesn't do for example is
it does squeezed variability into two
dimensions but it does it was stochastic
rating in this one and so that's a
little random so if you run tease me
many times you'll get different results
so the next round this project I'll talk
about is so I've talked a lot about how
really understanding the shape of the
manifold helps you visualize helps you
figure out the differences between
experimental conditions it helps you
restore or transcripts so can we do some
of this with deep learning which adds to
it all the other features that deep
learning has just even increased
scalability and the ability to do many
things at the same time because you have
some sort of deep model through which
you can process your data
heydo and magic are both very scalable
and David worked a lot on making them
super scalable so I'm sure he wants a to
mention that but I'm sure you guys know
that in deep learning you can farm it
out to a you know a bunch of GPUs or
something the more jigglies you how that
you it is to paralyze this but if you
have a lot of CPUs that's fine so sassy
is an autoencoder based framework and
that's what the a stands for so we think
really hard about making these acronyms
so we the idea of saucy is actually to
find these kind of patterns emergently
in a neural network instead of using
some kind of diffusion based algorithm
space on constraints and regularization
and what we're trying to do with saucy
is we're trying to go to the realm where
we there's massive amounts of data
Jonathan was saying today that there's
massive amounts of TCR data for example
so if we have massive amounts of data
like single cell data collected on many
many samples we want to be able to run
it through this system and come out and
read a lot of patterns off the fact that
an autoencoder neural network is
essentially a nonlinear dimensionality
reduction as long as you have nonlinear
activations so again okay so what some
of the things that we design saucey to
do are from the ways the different
layers are regularized we can read these
patterns off the data so actually people
always complain that you don't know what
the inside
neural network is doing and that's not
the true in our case of our neural
network because the outside it's doing
one interesting thing which is denoising
data but other than that it's just
recreating its own input that's what an
autoencoder does the internal layers are
good for visualization we can read
clusters off one of the layers we can
batch a line or batch normalize them and
then we can also recreate the output so
those the different layers and then
finally like it gives you sort of the
nonlinear dimensionality reduction on
particular patients can give you
stratifications of the patient's
themselves so I guess you don't need an
explanation of deep neural networks an
autoencoder was first introduced many
many years ago I don't know when it was
first introduced it was very it was
popularized in this science paper in
2006 and the idea is very simple that
the only penalty that the neural network
natively enforces is that the input be
recreated at the output and so this
makes it unsupervised you don't need any
labels and it means that if you have
reduced dimensions in the middle that
they have some kind of dimensionality
reduction going on so this is more
specifically what chasity looks like so
Safi has an MMD penalty or a penalty to
online batches enforced on its lowest
dimensional layer so the idea here is
that you treat the batches as different
distributions and align them there's a
layer that's two-dimensional that you
can use for visualization there's a
layer that has a special regularization
that we call that information dimension
regularization that binarize --is
activations or makes them easily
binarize Abal and there you can read
clusters off the data and finally the
output layer do noises the data because
it's trying to recreate the data after
throwing off all these dimensions in the
middle this because I defaced when the
stuff that you showed earlier it seems
like the particular arimin traces sheets
make a lot of difference
Tyrel business performance and furious
is like are using simply clean water is
trying to use of the probable state law
so so saucy is it's not stochastic all
that we have other significant role
networks it is using a simple
reconstruction loss like mean squared
error yeah and but there's penalty terms
due to the regularization so there's an
yeah but they're all added to the yeah
and I can I can go over that I think I
have some slides to go over how how I
can strain it so we yeah we constrain is
so that layer is giving us some people
do register is but you can have and
actually Elsa I don't think that layer
sizes similar as is shown here I think
it's a it's as fan-out layer it's sparse
so the visualization again you can
compare to these other methods like PC
eighties knee and things like that you
just take the two-dimensional layer and
visualize it that it's the
representation for the cluster until the
idea was this is that if you have some
cluster of cells you want to be able to
read off which cluster they're in and
the within cluster variation is only
stored in a small range on top of this
binarization it's still there because it
recreates it but the majority of the
signal that these nodes are giving is
which cluster it's in so this particular
cluster is encoded by basically 0 1 1
and you know a different cluster could
be encoded by something different so the
way you do this is we penalize for
activation entropy as as in fun Neumann
entropy so if you take all of your
activation values and you treat them as
a probability distribution and you
compute Shannon entropy on it
if all your nodes are activated to
roughly the same level then you'll have
high fun knowing and entropy if you can
call it that if one of them is one and a
lot of them are zeros or a few of them
are ones and a lot of them are zeros and
you have low activation entropy and so
this gives you sort of an erisa ball
entries or activation so with no
regularization you see a lot of things
are activated middle high l1
regularization which a lot of people use
just avoids the very high value and then
they're pushed over and you still have a
lot of entropy there but our
regularization gives you a binarize able
shape so if you round it or actually
binarize it you get cluster level
information rather than cell level
information from this and that's the
main idea of the regularization on the
layer that reads off the clusters for
the badge effects this is an embedding
of patient one versus patient two and
this is a dengue patient data set
and we use a probabilistic distance
that's been years a little bit in neural
networks but not too much it's called
maximal mean discrepancy and you can
compute this at the batch level you're
computing the batch one B have minimal
probabilistic distance to batch two but
it still has to reconstruct and do these
other things so it encourages it to sort
of minimally align the data and not
totally Rhys Crandall it so for the red
and the blue are a different patient so
the embedding is mainly organized by
patient which we don't want we want to
see we want the batch effects between
when the patients were measured what
time of the day all that to go away so
after I'm MD you see that it's organized
by cell type so now we can see how much
cd3 positive cells both these patients
these patients have and things like that
I don't know
so we tried this on the stange data it
was from
hanson bangalore was a neural biology
department and NIMH hands so they gave
us it's something like sixty patients
and and they visited two times and then
there's an additional number of patients
who came with them and they're the
healthy controls we're living in the
same environment and so there were 180
files each of them have many many cells
and so totally this data was 20 million
cells and you had to batch normalize
between one hundred and eighty different
files and there's the few better
normalization tools that are out there
don't really normalize that this scale
they do two conditions or something like
that
you see what the cells look like if you
combine all the Acutes and the healthy
versus the convalescent so kind of
lesson are the acute people they came
back some weeks later and there are
souls are starting to look a lot more
like the healthy it's just kinda a check
but you see that there's no sort of
batch effect you can't see each of the
acute patients separately or anything
like that it's it's a unified manifold
so on this unified manifold you can go
ahead and cluster like it's one dataset
which wasn't possible before there's
other methods that will cluster totally
separately and then try to match these
clusters and it turns out to a huge
problem instead you can just cluster the
this data as if it's one data set and
you come up with these populations of
cells we find that some of the
populations of cells for example are
very interesting they're those there's
the TCR Gamma Delta population and we
saw that a lot in the acutely infected
patients that they have sort of like NK
cells almost they have some innate
activity they show signs of innate
activity and this is a rare population
but we can still pick up a systematic
difference so then you can see these
signatures of these different cell types
for the different patients that are
acute convalescent or healthy and then
you could embed it again with with an MD
based the MMD based distance we see that
all the patients themselves are
stratified where the left side of the
embedding is a lot of the acute patients
and the right side
is is convalescent and you see people
are kind of listening to different
different extents and things like that
and then you can associate this with the
proportions of different clusters that
you see in your clustering and of course
the point that I was making is that
you're running all of this through these
neural networks that are tricked out or
whenever so it should be very scalable
and we actually do find that it's very
scalable so we've compared against so
k-means in fina graph or clustering
methods t sneeze sort of a clustering
but also visualization method say this
the old fates are compared against that
nun supervisor 8pc a neural network
completion M&N is a type of best
normalization diffusion maths all of
these things and it's super super fast
come faster than everything besides I
think it was PCA and that's because now
PCA is done with random projection
matrices really quickly but PCA doesn't
give you a very very good results for
your randomly linearly projecting you're
losing a lot of information so quality
wise saw sees way better than any kind
of PCA because it does so many other
things and it's it's a nonlinear
nonlinear method so finally it's just
because John I added one one slide just
because Jonathan was talking a lot about
dynamics so we have a neural network
that we're training also to predict
dynamics in these things and this
network is generative and it's
stochastic so we're calling this the
transcoder and because fate and these
other methods allow us to pick up
trajectories we're hoping to make these
trajectories and find some deep
representation of the logic that's used
to make these these transitions but
that's an ongoing project so do you if
we're hoping to test this on some kind
of evolution systems protein folding
system isn't it and things like that
those are the main projects that I want
to talk about again the main idea is we
pick up a lot of structure that could
otherwise go missing in data by using
very careful and nonlinear
dimensionality reduction in manifold
learning methods using graphs signal
processing and
so deep learning and we believe that
these have wide applicability much
beyond what I said to do the specific
data says that I was showing it on I
also have a lot of talented students and
postdocs and in my lab I try to get that
into Internet IBM let me know they were
doing a hackathon then and so it just
took pictures of them at a hack of them
and actually I think they were having a
lot of fun you know it looks funny and
of course we cooperate with a lot of
people at Yale including you know
immunologists infectious disease people
stem cell well this neurologists y'all
center for genome analysis um oh this
software I've talked about is on github
maybe besides transcoder papers are on
bio archive some of the papers on
related topics are and nipson I see mo a
lot of them are in bio archive also or
regular archives you can feel free to me
yeah so see is just in my pancreas
yeah we noticed that we have to even
though nobody in my lab likes or uses
our but I just want you as heaven bless
your code hittin huh let me make someone
do it um so let me know why are you an
RF an okay what are you guys code in
your own languages certain are you in
centuries this if you have any questions
let me know we have sort of additional
files on and they say something yeah
yeah so what up so you showed us
scalability game right so kind of thing
of you that's like magic and say you
need to think about this pairwise
distance and and that's that's where
you've got a little awkward saying yeah
that's exactly where you saw me go
yeah so it's so subtle but why in that
case I do I do have a slide that kind of
shows that you had well yeah sure but
also a related question is that can you
imagine using and you'll now have a way
to do the same thing like if we do use
the neural net could do the same thing
I'll show you so we don't get a neural
net we're going saucy doesn't doesn't
explicit so the last layer of sassy
actually gives you the same kind of risk
River constructions is magic and it most
closely compares to magic more so than
to the other imputation methods and this
is an actual innocence awesome
manuscript but this actually shows that
this neural network also learned semana
phone without diffusion and without us
having to define innocence meant some
other time just not incredible if you
the graph but using consents canes in
NLP we had only similar we have very
similar thing where you have a knowledge
graph like a large part of the relation
between the entity and then traditional
people use random walk to to to compute
the fusion policies you mean you're
doing me like word vector something like
that yeah nowadays we embed it into
embedding and then and then you can
compute any arbitrary thing without
doing any random walk that's a random
walk very expensive right yeah even
though we have yeah so here you can talk
about this this slider oh yeah oh so
instead of computing all paths between
points or constraining the paths to go
all through specific landmarks we fix
the number of led words but we pick
enough of them to accurately describe
the graph so now we essentially get a
linear so now that effusion goes from
original points to land my points series
little points but if you do the matrix
Association correctly the landmarks are
chosen to be sort of uniformly
representing the whole graph so he was
very little information by but we still
can exclude the vast majority of paths
so you literally a random sample there
yeah we actually use a spectral
clustering approach to remember it was
quite a you say image and fast random
sve so it's also for fast and so it's so
essentially the whole thing is linear so
he's almost a liar a little bit like a
random objection yeah we didn't ran a
projections to bigger the landmarks and
then we compute paths through to go
through how that works
just
and it works almost exactly the same
result as the original version guys you
can look up the fate either on by
archiver on cell sneak peek and he'll
show face comparisons and thousands of
supplemental figure isn't it so the
spike thing in the run time there is
that when you're not using as many
landmarks yes exactly that's a very good
observation so we use I think I default
something like 2,000 landmarks so when
you're you have fewer points in London
that number there's no point in doing
this and yeah so only really large
numbers does it help to do to people in
immersive quite exactly the other
motivation for sausage isn't it just
scalability it's also that all these
tests are implemented on some kind of
unified representation of the data so we
find that some clustering methods they
might represent the data as graph or
some kind of cloud and then you have a
fashion emergency med that represents
data as canonical correlation dimensions
or something and there's very disparate
stuff and the different features you're
reading off the data are not made from
the same representation each other TC in
your data there's no guarantee that TC
picks up the same clusters as k-means
because I have just different algorithm
didn't reverse invasions there was one
of that reasons yeah when you did
stochastic gradient descent you've
passed the gradient all the way back so
all the layers are coordinated here we
have one representation cyst so just
kind of guarantees that you get the same
clusters as your visualization so that
clustering or where you use the
information
measure to constraint is that so that's
gonna effectively pick a forcible push
you towards picking a single single you
can worsen the the nose to become binary
sort of digital either zeros or ones but
even more so this offender force than
that because a single one yeah another
one would be like l1 so sparsity
sparsity would just okay try to make as
many no to go to zero we're not doing
that ones it denotes these zeros are one
so you wanted binary digital so entropy
is being computed on each node
independent so each each node na Holy
One comes a probability oh Shannon
Shannon is repeating oh I'm calling it
my name an injury because it's like an
entropy of values rather than
probabilities that's why I was calling
it cross over cross over set purse /
it's a cross the nodes across yeah but
we don't see that it gives us a single
one because it's not it's necessarily a
sparsity penalty so usually the neural
network you will not make it 100 be
given that it can still reconstruct so
usually the vectors are whatever three
four ones but we don't we don't usually
do that we find some 100 we do a hunt
one house is you have to take the number
of nodes which will give you the number
of clusters and in this case actually we
don't know we don't know the number of
clusters they were staying here we don't
know the number cluster so we don't have
to define we've got to set the number of
clusters we get but we can we can
overall tweet the recognizer tweak the
granularity by upping this penalty or
donning this penalty but we don't know
exactly how many are good nesting like
to me Takumi's give us ten clusters or
something so how do you
some coefficient regulation so that's
sort of available it depends on if you
want really big clusters like few cells
versus B cells versus monocytes or if
you want to go inside the new cells and
see the different subtypes that's pretty
robust like we see that we change it
biology is pretty similar or whatever
test case we have like a few mixtures or
whatever this is pretty robust against
those
cool thank you guys
[Applause]